hey how's it going bros my name is
good meme i've had some so many [ __ ]
tech difficulties today
this is like the 20th time i try to
[ __ ] do this video
i'm really [ __ ] excited to play the
new rick and morty game i don't know why
i bother doing an intro because
most likely it's just not gonna [ __ ]
work is it is it working
okay i think it's working you see what
i'm talking about the green screen is
gonna look [ __ ] i'm sure the audio is
gonna be [ __ ] but
all right let's give it a go whoa
holy crap rick yes you made a morty
clone rick
oh my god i'm taller than you in the
entire garage to do it
this is so awesome
i need you to take this laundry and put
it into the washing machine
i can drink clean instructions first oh
you know there's a dry erase board on
the
put up yeah the dry erase board area
finally i wrote instructions on what oh
[ __ ] i shouldn't have done that my bad
let's have some more
[Music]
i sound like morty as well
crazy okay we need to put the laundry
got it yeah
[Applause]
wow rick he's a regular old morty clone
ah okay good
so now that this board walk up
oh my god this is so cool welcome to
purgatory the devil's not available
so you get me the double secretary what
the [ __ ]
we weren't actually expecting you to be
dead so soon so
if you don't want to be dead you can
just press that button
[Music]
morty clone listen uh i had to bring you
back for some really important stuff
that i can't get into right now because
me and morty have to go
some stuff's gotten out of hand the [ __ ]
is happening this is so cool
all right listen i made a teleport
system for you all you have to do is you
know
look in the direction you want to go in
the room and then click the track pad
button under your thumb just
just push the button down and you can
teleport to any part of the room oh [ __ ]
whoa all right now one last thing morty
clone there's a watch over there on the
shelves
i'm gonna need you to grab the watch and
put it on your wrist you'll be able to
call me using the watch this is very
important
all right morty clone what do you say
this is so cool it feels like a job
simulator i think it's the same
developers
initiating the reverse initiating
reverse safety
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
why am i doing this because i think this
is the
what does this do
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
some alcohol
how drunk can you get in this game yes
yes
yeah this [ __ ] thing
oh oh this is the gayest thing i have
ever done
oh my ah
yes yes
i'm 12. shut up
ah why not what's the worst thing that
can happen
hey i'm king morty that's right
[ __ ]
a [ __ ] sledgehammer whoa
i don't think i was supposed to do that
why is it so [ __ ] fun to just [ __ ]
around oh yeah the watch
okay oh good you found the watch
you're not as dumb as i thought this is
so cool call me back once you get the
lay of the land
so what am i supposed to do yes
what is this mr masix
[Music]
they should mimic every action you do
except for teleporting of course
i'm gonna call them you seeks
wait i can teleport a bunch of them hey
it's me
[Music]
more got it i'm mr maybe
thank you this is so awesome
i got it wait he can get it
thank you
receiving a part in the driveway now
since you can't leave the garage you're
gonna have to use some help so
that's the button on the me box it's the
green and blue box on the shelf there
that should help you out even an idiot
could figure this one out
yeah what the [ __ ] is that
okay so i can't go there but i can get
the me six to get it for me
that's cool [ __ ] am i gonna throw it to
myself this is so
[ __ ] weird catch
ah what did i just touch
oh my god i think i did something bad
if you're gonna mess with it at least
use it correctly
you like that whoa it's oh [ __ ] it's
ticking
oh oh oh no oh i broke it
oops oh great they don't make them like
they used to probably a good idea not to
order these off of lord's list
i'm gonna need you to order me another
one of these things clone morty head
over to the
my workbench and um i'll activate my
computer remotely
using my remote device
why is this so fun to just [ __ ] around
what is this
oh this is his mouse pad okay
uh we need to order what the [ __ ] is
this porn
no i don't want to get a goddamn spam
everywhere
goddamn porn what the [ __ ]
oh that can't be good consult the
troubleshooting guy
repair my porn infested computer
great how do i do that great way to go
clone more you broke my computer you
really have a delicate touch
i'm gonna need you to fix it the
instructions are uh in the cabinet door
don't worry i got this
just put it in the basic actions
all right we need a new fuse it's
probably down here
hey be careful morty there's a monster
down there he's not really dangerous
he's just an [ __ ]
so i get the fuse from
this thing okay
a clone's first portal don't be afraid
just walk through it this is so [ __ ]
cool
whoa
[Music]
this is so cool jesus christ
i don't know what to say i'm speechless
this game is so [ __ ] up looks like
that battery needs to charge
battery needs to charge [ __ ] everything
is just [ __ ] broken
guess i'll go back
[Music]
uh this looks like a battery
check out my microburst machine clone
morty what the [ __ ] just happened
anywhere
what is happening
what do i do oh my god
wait i shrank oh i put it there okay
[Music]
what is happening
sure sure sure
[Music]
what the [ __ ]
oh i'm it's charging it i got it
[ __ ]
[Music]
this is so annoying
is it working
[Music]
yay i did it
yes okay we got the battery
[Music]
now let's go through the [ __ ] porta
no wait we don't need the part oh yeah
we do need the part
[ __ ] how did i get the portal again
right here portal one
[Music]
got it portal battery
open fuse i'll save that one for later
[Music]
change diffuse not a problem and then
last but least
we need a new ram a new ram everyone
hey you got a ram down there
he wants food give me a metal apple and
a carrot hammer what the actual [ __ ] are
you smoking
okay i think i saw him there's a hammer
you know what they say hammers don't
hurt people people hurt people
good one rick good one where is the
carriage do we have
carrots everyone nope that's not it
maybe in the fridge hell yeah
okay i would eat it but uh [ __ ] it
carrot hammer
oh
all right he wants a metal apple as well
not a problem sir
not a problem now let's just find some
scrap metal
hammer um
this game is so [ __ ] dumb i love that
screwdriver i mean whatever it's calling
anyways
that's the middle apple cool
here you go buddy
yay
oh [ __ ] okay
all right we got the ram done
yeah boy oh
looks good as new nice job clone morty
try ordering that device now
it'll teleport in over by the laundry
machine once you order it oh yeah that's
the computer can also be a good place to
order things you need
it's amazon
charge to jerry smith oh [ __ ] it's there
yes what oh thank god
you got the part okay it took you long
enough
that part you're holding is of critical
importance you're gonna use it to
retrieve an extremely powerful item
but it's not gonna be easy it's gonna be
one of the hardest things you've ever
done
it's going to be very confusing it's
going to be very difficult
it's going to be really challenging this
[ __ ] is about to get kicked up
like a hundred notches and when you're
ready for the fight of your life
give me a call back on the little wrist
phone that i
did that i made for you the fight of the
okay we gotta gear up
mr horse i want that painting so bad
it's [ __ ] amazing
all right sounds like we're gonna have
to gear up properly i'm gonna have to
make the most deadliest weapon of all
time
cucumber hammer i'm ready wow that's all
the time you needed to prepare for your
impending doom
hey i got the hat all right listen i
opened up a new location for you in the
portal just select the new location with
the arrows on the portal wall lever and
then you know once you've selected it
pull the lever and a portal will open up
automatically for you you're going to
want to grab the device you bought on
the internet you're going to want to
bring that with you
okay i'm ready
okay here we go
where the [ __ ] am i hey
all right clown morty
attach the device to the bottom of the
plunger
bottom of the what oh we're in
oh this is so cool
[Music]
why am i doing this jerry if the toilet
doesn't flush stop crying great
the [ __ ] is this laxative
did i really need to explain it oh wait
i do you know i just took a [ __ ]
oh my god can i brush my teeth
[Music]
i don't know why i tried this obviously
it's not interesting okay
nailed it now what
where'd it go i mean look if you want me
to spell it out for you
the thing goes in the thing you know i
mean it's a plunger
there we go
what the [ __ ] is this game
[Music]
open the toilet tank make sure there's
liquid in the tank
okay
well there's some wine
this is how rich people uh have their
what the bathroom is this what is this
all right good job morty i i told morty
you know to use the bathtub to deposit
that thing but
insisted on the toilet now we have to
grab it now that we have it
grab it and head back through the portal
are you [ __ ] kidding me
this is what i came for
[Music]
i'm collecting [ __ ] that's what i'm the
[ __ ] where do you come ah clone morty
you're finally back from your little
bathroom adventure
listen i need to upgrade the car for a
very important outing that i won't
get into right now anyways i'm gonna
need you to plug the
seat into that seat shaped hole in the
engine area
okay oh there
haha mega seed artificial intelligence
microprocessor this is so [ __ ] weird
good we're gonna need some help
upgrading this car uh since you can't
talk go ahead and
call me on your watch thing you know the
the thing on your wrist oh
wait the clown's right in the happy
bottle oh
okay all right you're ready to go huh
all right i'm gonna need your help to
upgrade the rest of the car hey rick
how how's the clone supposed to know how
to fix the car you know i mean it's just
a dumb clone
morty the instructions are simple yeah
right rick i bet you
you you couldn't figure it out shut up
morty all right we got this [ __ ]
thing whatever he does contains
engine repair manual
how do i what do i do with this
oh what the [ __ ] this is so weird
oops why do i just feel like i'm rick's
[ __ ] [ __ ]
i i don't think this clown's gonna be
able to figure it out i mean this is a
really complicated one shut up
it's very simple they have to do is read
the instructions they'd figure it out
yeah you know but
i i don't know man i i don't i mean we
could be here for a while you know
morty it's easy even you could figure it
out
rick i'll figure something out i i
figured out that you're an [ __ ]
all right morty just quit quit quit
bitching for [ __ ] sake they flew
everywhere
that's an upgrade
what do you call that [ __ ]
incorrect combination please try a
little harder
what the [ __ ] all right i can do this
if it's this one it doesn't [ __ ] work
unless there's no red
okay this one it's not
if it's this one then there has to be
[Music]
two red which it can't be because it
can't
have one link with no duplicate
more than one so it can't be this one
if it's this one
same thing
am i missing some
i think i'm missing one
wait i think i got it oh my god
yes interconnect why do that take me so
[ __ ] long
oh my god i'm a [ __ ] idiot
what now what now
not more please
is that another [ __ ] battery
well i guess it's time to do this again
oh [ __ ] there's more of them now
it's like a weird simon says game it's
kind of fun
[ __ ] this is stressing me out
[ __ ] [ __ ]
yes
shut up
[Music]
are you kidding me
no i was so close
[Music]
really
[ __ ] done
okay you got your new battery
fully charged micro version so connected
i hope that came from a conflict-free
microphone nitro
where the [ __ ] do i get that ah you
ducked it
hey morty catch
is that a pepsi it's a black fish i love
bluffers
where'd he go i am the car
i made a mixtape too
your mixtape sucks mine is better
okay that's why my tape has no music on
it
great cassette tapes are for [ __ ]
i think i just blew it up
wait i gotta throw it
stupid clone morty okay so
we're gonna have to get a mr meesley
throw it over there
we're gonna have to give it to myself oh
i got it
oh this is so cool oh my god
are you serious come on mr meeseeks
a little further now
oh i'm standing really close to the
light
that's it no
[ __ ]
you're useless
i almost just [ __ ] died okay it's not
funny
almost there almost there um
yes yes is it going in
i can't tell is it go yes
all right morty summer it looks like the
car is ready to go so
let's get rolling we got [ __ ] to do
see my [ __ ] hand jesus christ all
right
really cool game i really enjoy it but
[ __ ] out
smash that like button and i'll see you
bros
in the next video thank you so much for
watching breakfast